buner nennt sich die kaffeezeremonie die
fast allen äthiopien heilig ist vor
allem hier in der region kaffa sie soll
dem café sogar seinen namen gegeben
haben sie gilt als die keimzelle der
pflanze aber der klimawandel bedroht
offenbar den kaffee cousin mohammed baut
die bohnen schon lange an was er seit
einigen jahren an seinen pflanzen
beobachtet macht ihm sorgen
als ich anfing wuchs der kaffee sehr
schön mit guten blättern die
sonneneinstrahlung war nicht zu stark
der regen wir ernteten viele bohnen aber
nach 56 jahren wurden die blätter
schlechter
durch die steigenden temperaturen wurden
auch die kaffeebohnen weniger die
qualität der ernte ließ nach mohammeds
pflanzen stehen in den tiefer liegenden
gebieten der region kaffee arabica ist
eine sensible pflanze die am besten
zwischen 18 und 21 grad celsius gedeiht
wird es wärmer wird der anbau
schwieriger wissenschaftler gehen davon
aus dass bis 2080 mehr als drei viertel
der arabica kaffee anbauflächen in
diesen höhen nicht mehr nutzbar sein
könnten
kaffee ist die pflanze die mit am
stärksten vom klimawandel bedroht ist
wenn es wärmer wird dann leidet zunächst
die qualität und dann gehen die pflanzen
eventuell ganz ein
das kann neben den temperaturen auch ein
krankheiten liegen die pflanze verliert
ihre widerstandskraft gegen den in denen
kaffee noch heute wächst könnten in der
zukunft nicht mehr funktionieren
außerdem sind rund 60 prozent der wilden
kaffeesorten bedroht durch abholzung und
klimawandel
unterwegs in einem wald mit bild kaffee
gerade diese varianten sind ein
wichtiges genetisches reservoir für
kultivierten kaffee durch einkreuzung
können sie kommerzielle sorten
resistenter gegen umwelteinflüsse und
einheiten machen ein geniales gab die
situation dass eine kaffeesorte durch
eine krankheit passt ganz verschwunden
war
es waren die wilden sorten durch die sie
quasi wiederbelebt wurde
15 millionen menschen sind
wirtschaftlich vom kaffeeanbau in
äthiopien abhängig und langfristig
womöglich in ihrer existenz durch den
klimawandel bedroht